In the previous section,
we saw that rates compare two
quantities with different units.
For example, 25 miles per gallon,
$0.23 per ounce, or 0.7 hits per at-bat.
These are all rates.
But what if we want to compare two
quantities with the same units.
Then we don't want rates.
What we actually want
are called ratios and
they're very similar to rates but
the two quantities have the same unit.
For example, let's say a TV
commercial says something like
three out of five dentists
recommend Toothtaste.
Which of course is
the flavorful toothpaste.
This is a ratio because what we're
actually saying when we say three out of
five dentists, is three dentists out of
five dentists prefer this toothpaste.
It compares dentist to dentist.
Can you identify the following
examples as rates, ratios, or neither?
Eight out of ten cats prefer Whiskas,
gas costs $4.25 per gallon, out
of 500 graduates, 200 got business jobs,
and the Eiffel Tower is 324 meters tall.
In each of these boxes,
enter either rate, ratio, or neither.